la cosa che mi fa più ridere che in blog
essendo in quei video dove mi si vede
proprio pieno sono anche puntualmente
qui video dove mi non mi faccio la barba
sono tipo tutto smith io coi capelli
sono quelli in cui mi si vede in pieno
fantastico e aspetto il blog per essere
più trasandato possibile poi il giorno
dopo mi metto a posto letto letto le
maglie taka at the youtuber
professionista che sono attenti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj oggi ragazzi un blog un po
particolare perché la settimana scorsa
il weekend scorso sono andato al games
week
perché sono stato invitato da hp hp
aveva lo stand al games week
mi ha detto farisei vieni a fare le cose
nel nostro stand grazie che mi mandi
messaggi quando faccio il logo ragazzi
comunque essendo andato al gamesweek
obbligato quello che sono riuscito a
bloggare quindi ragazzi vi lascio al
video e vi faccio vedere come è stata
l'esperienza del gesù
[Musica]
questo vorrei zombie dead rising dead
rising cerca di vedere quando piove
quindi i miei capelli non stanno mai
nella vita
io non siano fatti bene per una volta
che esco che esco mai
e invece niente guarda aspettato
ma stiamo andando a londra
da capire se questa gente non sapremo
mai ragazzi
non ci arriveremo mai dobbiamo andare là
non ci arriveremo mai
ciao sono in mezzo metro
posto ciao
giacciono sotto mano
vi lascio lorenzo tengo faccio un
ricordo
votate lega
abbiamo tutti
era
siede dietro alle quali voglio vedere
tesi che tutti
basta
[Musica]
inventato
la poltrona in mezzo a tutti quanti
tutto quanto il games week
il problema è che sta roba qua si muove
avanti indietro volate a giocare a
qualsiasi cosa ho neanche pokémon riesce
trovare esattamente come il mio computer
fase che a me mi si accende in un'ora e
mezzo e concreta che faccio martin galli
ho sentito martin gara che lui non ha
emozioni
qui sta fermo non si è mosso come
riuscito a fare gol davanti anche un po
di persone
bello
comunque ragazzi voi che conoscete me
che sono timido non mi sono fatto
int imbarazzato ha garantito
imbarazzato
messa durante l'interrogazione ci hanno
regalato hanno regalati dolcetti e
adesso meakin l'intesta prende 16 morto
uniti e borno vai papa saggia
cos'è sta roba così ma tosi mangiato
questo noi non lo mangiano mai ragazzi
mi stanno morendo i miei due migliori
amici perché fanno il test della del
cibo dei fan
e adesso andiamo a rubare le carte miste
panino che gli hanno regalato dai mente
ma gli devi condividere un po come devi
condividere perché non condivide con me
grazie papà guarda che bello ha scritto
eri un solo senso allora adesso vi
faccio vedere come la situazione di ogni
vedere cosa hanno regalato in mezzo
allora questo è mio
questo è mio aiuto via
a roma papa aiuta ne ho preso papa
no
sono usciti bene alla situazione
politica
ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao antonio
471 aperture per niente
voglio che mio zio è vero non è mio zio
ma si può uscire male sobri 2 fai finta
che lo ricordano tutti guardano tutti
vai prova
vai
[Musica]
bolle quindi regazzoli questo è stato il
games week per me sedia parte è stato
superfigo tratto volevo nuovamente
ringraziare hp per l'ospitalità e lo
stand era anche super organizzato quindi
grazie mille anche se ho fatto una
figura di merda alla scelta di rocket
league come videogame era super ok e tre
assoli questo era il video di games week
settimana prossima aspettatevi il video
di amsterdam che sarà una bomba pazzesca
quindi lega solis spero che vi sia
piaciuto cose mio bisogno di un momento
è un mi piace anche a pressioni facebook
come nel video descrizione senza vestiti
siete miccichè diamo il prossimo filo
teso ragazze